there's some big big things on the way
big things oh
did they ever cardi b in offsets family
is getting a little bigger
following the rapper's surprise debut of
her baby bump during the bet awards she
took to instagram with these maternity
photos on monday
and cardi got sentimental in the
captions oh yes honey
for this photo she predicted what kind
of big sister culture will be
pointing out that her firstborn will
have the same age difference as cardi
and her younger sister hennessy
she wrote i just know these two will
love each other so much
and argue so much since they're three
years apart just like me and penny
but one thing for sure is they'll have
each other's back like no one else ever
will
i don't know i just get too emotional
when it comes to that kid
next to this pic of hubby offset
cradling her baby bump
cardi wrote we listened to each other
communicated prayed and then god blessed
us and our family with another little
blessing
our home feels so blissful and very busy
but we are ready and
so happy thank you so much everyone for
the congrats and well-wishes
[Applause]
leading up to the pregnancy reveal
sunday night migos sang
cardi's praises on the red carpet is
cardi getting to check as the fourth me
goes because she's doing all those
videos
you know my my my baby boss herself you
know what i'm saying
it's three boys and then she about you
know herself you dig what i'm saying
yeah shut up okay barty with the baby
bump
oh my god
hardy also had five nominations heading
into the night
taking home two awards for her hit song
with megan the stallion
[ __ ] goes
to cardi b featuring [ __ ]
cardi shared this hilarious backstage
moment to her instagram stories where
she gave a good reason for not
accepting her award in person
and if her live tv reveal seems familiar
there's a good reason
i was here before all of this guess who
acted now now you got an audience
when cardi announced she was pregnant
with culture she did so while performing
on saturday night live in 2018.
listen this loves got you this messed up
in the back
you want a random shake up in your bed
she don't even know your middle name
[Music]